[Music]
my mother called death night 72 has
uncovered a secret weapon in fallout 4
by digging through the game's files the
weapon is a harpoon gun which replaces
the railway gun if you have it in your
arsenal the animations are a tad janky
as the gun likely wasn't supposed to be
discovered but it is possible that
Bethesda intends for it to become
available in fallout 4s upcoming DLC
there's also speculation that the bubble
animation which happens upon scoring a
kill with the harpoon gun suggests that
fallout 4 was going to have an
underwater sequence details on how to
get the gun in your game can be found in
a story on GameSpot that said Bethesda
are urging you to be careful when using
PC console commands to mess with your
game bethesda marketing manager Pete
Hines said that PC console commands will
never be available on ps4 or Xbox one
explaining use of the console is not
supported or recommended on PC that kind
of thing isn't permitted on console
anyway he added that doing so can easily
mess up save games so you've been warned
if you aren't all that worried though
GameSpot has compiled some of the best
fallout 4 console commands on site so
check that one out
let me know if you prefer to module
games or play the vanilla version and
why for all the latest fallout things
stay tuned to games like